N
EARLIER THAN THAT.
AT 18 WEEKS, STRESS ARISES WHEN
NEEDLES ARE USED TO DRAW THEIR
BLOOD IN UTERO.
THE JOHN HOPKINS UNIVERSITY OF
HEALTH, HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
TAKING THE POLITICS OUT OF IT,
ROE V. WADE OUT OF IT, JUST THE
SCIENCE OF US, WE KNOW THAT
CHILDREN IN UTERO, FETUSES, A
DEVELOPING HUMAN BEING IN UTERO
FEELS PAIN, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 15 AND 20
WEEKS BABIES WILL ACTUALLY
RESIST THE INSTRUMENTS OF
ABORTION.
ROE IS BASED ON VIABILITY BUT
VIABILITY HAS BEEN CHANGING.
BABIES SURVIVE NOW AT
APPROXIMATELY THE HALFWAY POINT
OF PREGNANCY AT 21 AND 22 WEEKS,
BABIES HAVE SURVIVED OUTSIDE THE
WOMB, SO IRONICALLY WE SOMETIMES
DO FETAL SURGERY INSIDE THE WOMB
OF THE MOTHER TO SAVE THE BABY'S
LIFE AND AT THE SAME AGE, NOW
SURGICAL INSTRUMENTS ARE USED TO
ABORT A BABY.
THERE IS A GREAT IRONY AND NOW
YOU CAN BARELY TALK ABOUT IT.
I WITNESSED IT AS A MEDICAL
STUDENT AND I WILL TELL YOU IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHICH SIDE YOU
PROTEST ON ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
IF YOU SEE THE ACTUAL IMAGES OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT A BABY
RESISTING AN ABORTION, IT WILL
WEIGH ON YOUR CONSCIENCE.
TODAY YOU CAN BARELY TALK ABOUT
IT, NURSES CAN GET FIRED IF THEY
DON'T PARTICIPATE, STUDENTS ARE
RIDICULED.
MOST OF THE MEDICAL INSTITUTIONS
HAVE TAKEN A STAND SUPPORTING
ABORTION UNTIL THE THIRD
TRIMESTER.
>> Tucker: IT DOES NOTHING TO
RESTORE CONFIDENCE I